okay
check check check check check check
check
trying to come back trying to come back
trying to come back
okay you guys can hear me now
at least
she can't see me
[Music]
[Music]
there we go
man note to self
[Music]
okay
all right we're back we're back we're
back we're back
christy with a gifted membership christy
thank you so much
looks like reflex
just got that gifted membership christy
thank you so much for supporting the
stream and getting that gifted
membership over yeah sorry about that
guys i um
note to self never it was from where i
started that recording
and then i tried to open up windows
what was it somebody commented about um
i'm not recording so now i should be
able to pull it up
nope my windows explorer is still not
responding but i'm not i'm just not
touching it
just not even touching it right now yeah
exactly the wallpaper
johnny with a gifted membership as well
and sinjin
just got that gifted membership
yeah everything was still showing that
it was going for me but
yeah it just was not um
[Music]
not streaming to everybody
christy with another gifted membership
christy thank you so much for spreading
the love on the channel tonight
scarlett girl 27 got that one
all right so for those of you that are
getting the gifted memberships let me
show you something here
let me show you something
you just unlocked all of these little
all these right here
[Music]
no i didn't i didn't accidentally
that's probably seemed like what
happened that i hit stop streaming but
no i hit stop stop recording
but what had happened was i tried to
open windows explorer
and when i opened windows explorer
i just started getting spinning
and so i thought okay maybe that's
spinning because i'm still recording
maybe i need to turn off the recording
so i tried to turn off the recording
well then that just started spinning i
think
i don't know if that's what killed obs
or if um
because the windows explore is still not
working
it's just like i'm still spinning so i'm
just gonna finish out the stream and
then i guess restart my whole computer
because
things are working for right now
there we go jason's showing off the
emotes i was trying to type in another
chat but it was like you don't have uh
it's like there is no live stream so i
thought we had died again
the stream is haunted now
oh yeah i could i could just uh pull it
up through google
it was the um
hogsmeade wallpaper
oh that doesn't work hogsmeade hogwarts
legacy
wallpaper
why is it not showing up
no it's not that one either
oh man
i can't get it
retro i gotta read your comments which
ones james the stream kind of died for a
bit so
what if the haunted shop eventually gets
closed down hogsmeade gets smaller over
the years then when the marauders get
there it's now the shrieking shack
dude
oh my gosh
that would be insane
that would be insane and remember
troy levitt on the interviews with
podcast now if you guys have seen this
talked about
how he thought that one day
there might be things in hogwarts legacy
that become quote unquote canon like
people love them so much that
those things actually become part of the
what we potter fans consider
things that they adopt
eventually in maybe the movies or
something
that's a cool idea i like it
jaden people lucky getting those gifted
memberships
uh i don't think so dr robopanda yeah
dylan looks like dylan says he tried
by the way let me let me try something
here
actually like i don't know how much i
want to try with the way the way that
the uh
i mean we already had the bot filter
going crazy when we first started the
stream tonight
okay here we go so we're still good
i'm trying to get in a different window
here
oh man we just lost like
so many of our viewers though
when the stream died people are like oh
it's over i don't blame you i would i
would have thought the same thing
pop out chat
okay here we go
smash the like button
i'm going to add dylan as a moderator
i want to see if dylan can
i'm hoping if i add a couple moderators
that it will let you guys
post um
post links because i can't find the link
to the uh
the hogsmeade wallpaper i'd like to take
a look at that
nico here let's make nico a mod as well
doing well reflex doing well
400 viewers to 77 oh man
hey that's part of it you know gotta get
the technical uh
technical side
man i was hoping my pc was powerful
enough to do streaming and recording
together and it looked like it had been
until i started trying to
until i started trying to look at files
on my computer
dylan says what
you have been promoted sir if your marty
could post links okay nico and dylan are
both mods now
so if either one of them finds the uh
[Music]
prefix oh i wish you could change the
name of mods that'd be great we'd have
prefix and then we would have to have
like a head boy
head boy and head girl
they can deduct the house points
fastidio does seem like a good name for
a poltergeist i agree
retro is the headmaster yeah exactly
christy head boy and head girl we gotta
get both in there
hey you guys are all like what you just
start modding people
no i've been thinking about it for a
while that i need to add a few mods here
and i feel like dylan and nico are
nico has been following my my content
since i was streaming to like five
people on
twitch
honestly like what five years ago
what was your name on
on there nico
is your name different on twitch
hey have a good night johnny
johnny thank you so much for those
gifted memberships for the membership
yourself
happy birthday dude hope you had an
awesome birthday
and uh yeah i'm sure i'll see you around
online christy with another
gifted membership how are you let's see
who got that one
macy just got the gifted membership
so what do you get with the gift of
memberships guys so you get the um
[Music]
oh my goodness man
these allergies
uh